[Music]
tyler is in colorado springs hi tyler
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how's it going today dave better
than i deserve what's up
uh i'm kind of in a funny transitional
state in my life i'm getting ready to
transition out of the military and i'm
looking at living options once i get out
i'm gonna go to college on the gi bill
and
i've been really struggling with whether
or not i should rent or try to buy a
home but in doing some research
it doesn't seem like there's any way
that i can get pre-approved for a home
loan
and i understand that you hate va loans
can you can you clarify as to kind of
why
you you hate va loans so much and also
what your best advice is to me hate
might be a strong term but um
but number one va loans are more
expensive with fees
and interest rate than any of the big
three fha va or conventional
number two
va loans the reason most people
gravitate towards a va loan is you can
get a as you know you can get a house
with nothing down
yeah and that's that which means you're
too dead broke to buy a house
okay when you buy a house with no money
a house is not a blessing
okay
and so because here because you know the
air conditioner is going to go out next
week
okay so i want you to have a house i
just don't want to have you so that
that's the reason i don't i don't it
causes people to buy a home
and when they're in a position of
weakness rather than strength so what i
would tell you to do is uh rent the
least expensive thing that you can and
let's work on your career and work on
your goals and build up some money
okay so then in that case that leaves me
with one of two options i can either
live with my parents for 350 a month
which
yes that's awesome but how long have you
been in the military i've been in the
military for nearly five years when i
get out yeah that one's real home that'd
be really painful
yeah and and my parents i love them to
death great people but
it's it's difficult to live with them
and so my next option would be
um
would be renting a apartment for about
850 bucks a month yeah i try to get you
a roommate situation where you can get
that cut down but you don't need to be
back at home
it's just it's emotionally going to be
destructive for everyone involved
okay
and with that though i guess i have some
extra money in the bank that i could use
to float myself on the months that i
don't get paid by the va for the months
that i don't go to school or summer
break or whatever
um
but can you not work
i can work uh it's gonna be very
part-time i do plan on getting a
part-time job i actually have a job
lined up already
as soon as i get out so what are you
going to study and how long is it going
to take you
i'm going for a construction management
degree
and it's going to take me four years
i'll get my bachelor's and i should
graduate
by like 2026 somewhere in there right
well i graduated in four years with a
business degree
from the university of tennessee and i
worked 40 to 60 hours a week every week
okay
so very very part time is not necessary
you don't have to work that much because
you're not starving to death you've got
the stipend and everything but you also
have to sit on your butt
and all that extra money can go towards
saving up for when you want to buy a
house when you're ready to talk so the
more you work the more money you have
the quicker you get to that goal
and and if i were you i would take it a
step further and i would get a job in
construction anything you can do around
where you want to be meeting those
people that are doing what you want to
do what you're in school for that's just
going to fast track your whole plan yeah
get it get get your foot in the door and
start learning some hands-on while
you're learning in the classroom and
that's going to be you're going to come
out you know with three
major advantages towards your success
your military career your hands on the
job training and your academic
background you put those three things
together man you got some really good
taste in soup there i i think you got a
bright future when you do all that and
the construction guys will appreciate
you actually knowing what the flip's
going on from something other than a
textbook